so my YouTube channel just got
375 percent more views
than last month and grew by 50 000
subscribers in less than 28 days however
this growth could actually be hurting my
YouTube channel and so in this episode
of the think media podcast we're
actually going to be talking about
YouTube shorts and I have 10 lessons
tips and warnings about YouTube shorts
it's kind of like The Good the Bad and
the Ugly and as I was brainstorming this
episode uh myself and I think media team
actually came up with some different
titles and here's some of the titles
that didn't make the cut but I want to
share these with you to give you an idea
of what we're about to cover so here's
the first one YouTube shorts are like
drugs we had a wild night but dang the
next day sucked
that one didn't make the cut but that
was one of the titles uh here's another
one why I love and hate YouTube shorts
how about this YouTube shorts kind of
like post Malone's relationship with
alcohol
it kind of dark but these are just
brainstorms you know when you're
brainstorming titles you got to come up
uh here's another one YouTube shorts
ruined my YouTube channel
and then finally YouTube shorts are
awesome but they kinda suck
so anyways those are some titles that
didn't make the cut and as a side note
it is always good I think to brainstorm
titles eventually we landed with the
painful truth about YouTube shorts and
so in this episode I'm excited to get
into these 10 tips lessons warnings from
massive growth in fact 17 million new
views in the last 28 days more like 15
on think media our main Channel 375
percent more views than usual it's
pretty wild and so I've got a lot of
insights to share with you and lessons
that I've learned but today's episode is
brought to you by learnvideo2023.com
if you haven't heard we're doing a
three-day YouTube challenge that's all
about how to make big money on YouTube
with a small Channel how to get your
first or next a thousand subscribers
what's working to grow on YouTube in
2023 and what's been changing on the
platform and how to build a full-time
income without needing to be famous and
so if that sounds interested to you and
if you would just say you're serious
about growing on YouTube and either
starting or growing your channel I
highly recommend that you register for
this free challenge and you can go to
learn video2023.com or of course check
out the show notes to register let's
talk about what we've been learning here
at think media when it comes to YouTube
shorts number one the YouTube shorts
feed is the key to getting
massive viral traffic on YouTube so
a few shorts really broke out for us to
think media and the result was that in
the last 28 day days we got
17.4 million views on YouTube shorts now
where did the majority of those views
come from
94.2 percent came from the shorts feed
so to be clear if you're new to YouTube
shorts they're vertical videos that are
less than 60 seconds and typically on
YouTube you can get discovered on the
home page somebody could search for
something and they might find you on the
page there you can even get views on
YouTube from Google because someone
Google something and they find one of
your videos
um Channel Pages playlists there's just
different traffic sources but the shorts
feed essentially invented a new form of
traffic kind of like a Facebook feed
kind of like you're scrolling and
refreshing on Instagram there's now in
the YouTube app the ability to look at
these shorts feed and so virality in
terms of shorts and in terms of what we
experienced
is tapping into the shorts feed now our
most viral video
got
11.2 million views one video in just the
last 28 days it actually has more than
that that's how many views it got in the
last 28 days it's been out for a long
time but I'm skipping ahead in terms of
my points and so
um this video was about I interviewed
Patrick pet David for valuetainment and
I sat down with him and
um asked him questions about all kinds
of things and one of the questions I
asked him was about
Mr Beast uh people claiming oh him being
offered a billion dollars for his Empire
and him turning it down and so it was a
trending news story I was with somebody
who is smart and somewhat perhaps known
um I think let me know if you know pbd
if you're actually watching the live
recording of this
um valutainment and he you know
um is also very articulate and had a lot
of thoughtful things to say about it
I'll come back with some lessons about
the video of course Mr Beast we'd call
this trend surfing or influence surfing
um and then if it was edited well it was
a fascinating conversation and there's
some reasons why it kind of broke out
but this one video got 11.2 million
views which by the way is I want to say
the most viral video
that think media has ever seen now so
what's Wild is that in my career of
being on YouTube since 2007 when I first
started a channel for my church
I've never gotten that many views and
this short is not stopping and there's
other ones this is just the biggest one
which is fascinating because if all we
cared about was views and this is why
YouTube shorts are kind of like drugs we
had a wild night but dang the next day
sucked
um
you know if all we cared about was views
then it would appear that these are the
greatest days
of YouTube but I would argue that's not
true but hey it's cool to get 11.2
million views now another interesting
fact is that this particular short at
scale millions of people have watched it
and a lot are watching it every day
um the average percentage viewed of this
48 second short
is 91.4 there's a secret for you that
I've heard others confirm that if you
can get
over 90
percentage viewed on a short another way
to put it is basically close to
completion
the video is 48 seconds long and the
average person is watching it all the
way until 44 seconds by the way at the
time of recording this think media
podcast every two days this short is
getting 2.1 million views it's going
parabolic
you know if you know compared to what we
normally get now
here's number one creators are
experiencing exponential and rapid
growth through shorts the shorts feed is
also the key traffic for going viral all
right number two
post shorts and weight
post YouTube shorts
but then wait
so Sean you posted this short did did it
go viral right away it didn't in fact
check this out it blew up at day
150.
150 days after it was posted now it did
all right it was irking along it was
limping along more than limping it was
kind of jogging along compared to the
Views it's getting now not even whatever
forget the analogy but It ultimately it
was doing okay but when it shot up it
was day 150. so one thing when it comes
to this kind of a good YouTube
philosophy in general is commit to the
process commit to posting and then be
patient because videos can take off
later and they may not take off you know
instantly and so post shorts and wait
number three shorts don't pay very well
hmm okay
so
if your plan is to get monetized on
YouTube good plan but if that's your
plan on how you want to quit your job go
part-time full-time make a living
in my opinion it's not actually a very
good plan for the average Creator but
what's amazing is in our community right
we are seeing lots of people go full
time without needing to be famous
without needing to ever go viral now
what's cool is on their Journey they
will go viral here and there
uh and we call it vfm viral for me
because depending on your Niche it's not
about millions of views it's about
thousands of the right views
But ultimately when it comes to earning
money on YouTube YouTube shorts do not
pay very well so this breakout short
11.2 million views
earned me 500
and
36.74 cents
now by the way it's pretty cool you know
five hundo like a little walking around
money right 536 bucks it's a good it's
that pays your bills pays half your car
payment based on the average American
car payment plus you got insurance
um that's 11 million views for 500 bucks
let me give you some numbers of what's
happening over on our think media
channel
um
Longs and lives so traditional YouTube
videos
and live streams
we get
around 4 million views every month and
that's been just like clockwork it's
ranged from
3.8 to 4.3
and that's like our Baseline however
that earns the channel
a 7.36 RPM
in the last 28 days what is rpm how much
do we earn per thousand views 7.36 which
equates to nearly thirty thousand
dollars pretty good so think media in
the last
month has earned thirty thousand dollars
approximately from long form video
shorts on the other hand
and that's from four million views
shorts got 17 million views total across
all the shorts last 28 days
and we earned nine hundred dollars total
the RPM every thousand views we get on
shorts we earn six cents compared to
seven dollars and 36 Cents so the
comparison of how much you earn from
YouTube shorts versus Longhorn videos is
the Delta is shocking it's like it's
wild that's why I was coming up with
titles like YouTube shorts why I love
and hate YouTube shorts Why YouTube
shorts are kind of awesome but actually
sort of suck and I mean it's cool to get
the views but like what does that even
mean
so
number three YouTube shorts don't pay
number very well number four YouTube
shorts can grow your subscribers quickly
the breakout short that we had 17
million views grew our Channel 9400
subscribers
in the last 28 days YouTube shorts grew
our YouTube channel 50
000 subscribers
I mean that's why I love YouTube shorts
I think that's pretty dang cool and the
question is what is the quality of the
subscribers
the question is
how many and let me actually correct
that in last month
YouTube shorts grew our Channel
200 subscribers
and across all of our videos
um I'll have to look it up here I've got
my screen up but across all of our
videos
48.6
000 subscribers
forget all that that'll be an edit for
the podcast
so anyways YouTube shorts grew as 12 000
subscribers
um and so that's that's pretty cool so
YouTube subscribers number four YouTube
shorts can grow your subscribers quickly
and one breakout short grew our Channel
almost
10 000 new subscribers now again
this breakout short is getting 2.1
million views every two days
that is just some absolute you want to
talk about like highs and lows in roller
coaster of YouTube 2.1 million views
every two days is how much this one
breakout short our second place one's
getting 500 000 views every two days and
our third place one is getting 280 000
views every two days and these guys are
in the shorts feed man they're they're
burning it's we're it's it's it's time
to ride like we're crushing and then our
fourth place best viewed video is long
form long form long form and then we go
back into shorts what's been fascinating
is in my real-time views which is in
your analytics is where you dive in and
see uh at this view I think you're
seeing your top 30. or your top 20. and
shorts is now
for us taking over about half of those
spots
so no doubt about it like there's
something about using YouTube shorts
posting YouTube shorts being patient and
waiting and the fact that you can get a
lot of views and you can get a lot of
subscribers number five though
is subscribers don't matter as much as
you think they do
period across the the board I would
argue this is my thesis and if you're
here live on the YouTube channel I'm
curious
have you been noticing do you get do you
have a lot more subscribers than views
are you posting YouTube shorts
what are the results you've been getting
lately what's your opinion on the matter
but Business Insider recently did an
article that said YouTube subscribers
are quickly becoming an outdated Relic
and that in a 2023 world
there's Channels with millions of
subscribers that are getting thousands
of views and there's Channels with
thousands of subscribers that are
getting millions of views
so really subscriber subscribers are
kind of a vanity metric and here's what
some creators have been saying they've
been saying stuff like uh some of the
businesses coaching creators are rather
like brand deal companies and agencies
they've been telling creators that
having subscribers is cool but it
doesn't really matter if they don't care
about you as a person
we're going to come back to that
especially in the world of short form
content where your viewers are one swipe
away from moving on to someone else
think about your own behavior I've
actually been consuming more YouTube
shorts last night after uh I went to
this leaders Gathering I then picked up
some groceries from Safeway
um for my wife in Lake Stevens
Washington came home I heard you're not
supposed to eat three hours before bed
um and so what I did was I came home
and ate like the equivalent of four
dinners um right before bed so you know
not always making the best decisions and
as I sat at our kitchen table
and uh it was sushi that I got from
Safeway it's pretty good and um as I sat
there eating uh supper at 10 36 p.m I
was um it was actually my fourth dinner
too who cares it has nothing to do with
today's topic
it does because I was sitting there
watching shorts so I was swiping on my
phone and what I realized was while I
loved a lot of the content the YouTube
algorithm was was serving me I was
impartial to who the content was coming
from like I wasn't looking at the
channel
I wasn't
um subscribed I didn't subscribe to
anybody I was just swiping and consuming
and even getting value and perhaps
paying those creators six cents per per
thousand views uh with my consumption by
the way I'm a YouTube premium user so
you do earn from YouTube premium users
when they view your content and so
um all that to say is
having subscribers is cool but it
doesn't matter if they don't care about
you as a person especially in a world of
short form content where viewers are one
swipe away from moving on to someone
else
and where a lot of the content I was
watching and this is interesting because
our breakout short
is
ultimately me interviewing Patrick David
talking about Mr Beast
so the real question is you know whose
brand are you building
and are you really building a connection
or are you just getting a view and a lot
of the content I was watching you all
ever see David Goggins content you see
this guy you know he would like be
running it'll be like he'll be like I
got an email from a 22 year old
he said how do you stay motivated
I told him I said you gotta just wake up
punch fear in the face
and press record you know David Goggins
you ever heard of him if you didn't that
was kind of a weird little caveat and so
I'm seeing like David gotta get Goggins
content everywhere he's like this insane
he like broke the pull-ups record
but they're from channels that
are not actually him
and so if you see different craters or
different clips or different OPC and it
very well could be OPC stands for other
people's content it very well could be
used under fair use and it is a
potential approach to YouTube but whose
brand are you building and have you made
a connection
and so a lot of creators and influencer
Marketing Executives agree that a
rapidly growing subscriber count does
not necessarily translate into success
and longevity
that YouTube Fame otherwise brought
creators
that's why one of my potential titles
for this podcast was why YouTube shorts
ruined my channel
because we're getting all these
subscribers but I'm like what does it
mean really you know what are we really
accomplishing here
and I have more questions than answers
for you because we're in the wild wild
west of this
you know we're out here on the Oregon
Trail pioneering new land trying to
figure this thing out there's a lot of
conflict out here you know it's dramatic
like 1980
18 1883 come on Yellowstone pretty cool
help me in if you're here live in the
comments come on Harrison Ford in 1923
am I getting the years right let's stay
focused um number six making mistakes in
your video can trigger
engagement making mistakes and lead in
for this one because this is a very
tactical thing that's interesting
um officially just to Circle back 1883
is the show name and my wife and I
thoroughly enjoyed it I cried
um and uh I am kind of into the the
second one so number six making mistakes
in your video can trigger engagement
here's what's fascinating and if you
haven't seen this video you might find
it entertaining so
one of the case studies we're talking
about is shorts are 50 of our real-time
views right now about our top viewed
videos
they're generating 17 million views in
just a couple of weeks on our Channel
not only are they breaking out but
they're causing other shorts to break
out on the channel
which
they are building our brand because
there's there's Omar has got a short
that's crushing and I've got one where
I'm being interviewed is crushing and
then there's another one where I'm
talking direct to camera that's crushing
so they are kind of like creating a loop
that are promoting each other which is
really great however the biggest one is
me interviewing Patrick David talking
about Mr Beast being offered a billion
dollars here's what's funny the Comets
are the most entertaining thing I've
ever seen
so what pbd does is he goes hey let's do
some simple math and he pulls out and he
starts just doing math on his phone
which was pretty much it was pretty easy
for me to follow
I don't know if it was right or not
because I wouldn't be the you don't want
me reviewing your math you know what I
mean like hey Dad can you proof like my
math to see if I got the equations right
like that's not going to be
that's they'll put me in that role
but the comments are like simple math
and apparently
um maybe like the math was nonsensical
it didn't really make sense
um it was the wrong way to approach
it wasn't even an accurate assessment of
how you would calculate Mr BEAST's
Channel value or his views value but
here's why this is a good thing is watch
what happened
Patrick David starts he says let's do
some simple math which is almost like
the beginning of a story or it's an open
loop
so he's like okay let's think about how
many views this channel has got and what
are those views worth and and he goes on
and on he goes yeah so basically that'd
be like a billion dollars so I think
absolutely like him being offered a
billion dollars and so what ended up
happening were people like that was so
dumb like that was the wrong way to
calculate it or that was such a bad way
of calculating it but here is the
strategy and the tip not even that it
was a strategy
but it can be and I got an example
making mistakes in your video can
trigger engagement
if people people go nuts they're like
horrible math they're like yeah right
but once the opening up of the loop of
the equation of needing to hear okay
where is he going with this how is he
coming in this conclusion and it carries
you until the end of the video so
average view duration is maxed out
because of the mistake let me go a
little bit deeper
I was at Social Media Marketing world
and we're going to be releasing this
episode on the think media podcast so
definitely make yours make sure you're
subscribed and you know you may watch
this on YouTube or listen on Spotify or
Google so wherever you're subscribed
uh be looking for this episode so Austin
Armstrong
has been blowing up with vertical video
across platforms
and he actually has a very interesting
tactic
that he's learned in terms of he
actually purposely makes mistakes in his
videos and here's what I mean
so he does
um a lot of videos like rating top
websites for business owners or like
cool websites like five websites that'll
help you do this
but one of the things he'll do is he'll
purposefully mispronounce words
for example he'll say like as the
philosopher Socrates says
and it should be Socrates but he'll say
Socrates
and boom the comments go viral like
people go oh this guy's so dumb he said
Socrates how dare you dishonor the
greatest now the way he figured this out
was by actually accidentally making
mistakes as humans do and then realizing
it triggered something because again it
was like just me talking to pbd he's
just like quickly doing a very
approximate estimation of how a business
could come to the conclusion that they
should offer Mr Beast a billion dollars
and so it wasn't that big of a deal it's
like relax but the internet is
undefeated
and so when you make a mistake just
something to consider it triggers
engagement and so he started to realize
like okay if I actually purposely make
mistakes or purposefully include things
that are weird or or awkward and so it's
actually become a part of his community
and his tribe even for example one of
the things he does is he shares the
screen and this is just Austin stuff I'm
not saying whether you should or should
have do this just sharing Insider
information
he opens up software on his computer and
he's screen sharing and what he actually
will do is he'll create folders next to
the software he's about to open and
it'll say something like
uh
downloads Hunter Biden's laptop
it'll like say like next to it it'll say
something super like kind of like a
sketchy folder like the Mar-A-Lago
Trump files or something like that so
what will happen is is as he's just
going in to teach you how to use a
software and he goes to his desktop and
he double clicks the software and opens
up he doesn't say anything about it is
somebody will Spot It
they'll start a debate and a
conversation did you see what was on his
desktop oh my gosh
watch time doubles because they have to
re-watch it you can't scroll on shorts
or vertical videos
and what will actually happen is new
people that discovers his content will
go to the comments and they'll be like
oh this is so you know what the heck
dude who is this guy like why does he
have downloads from Hunter Biden's
laptop on his computer like all this
different stuff and then his core
audience will be like obviously you're
new here because it's kind of like a a
joke or an ongoing theme if you know him
kind of like in The Simpsons there's
like always something different written
on the chalkboard by Bart Simpson like
he's always writing something different
in the folder next to the and uh anyways
the lesson is making mistakes can in
your video can trigger engagement now
maybe you don't want to like force a
mistake it feels weird and I would agree
with that you're not like it's kind of a
weird thing to do
here's why this is super empowering
I think that
a lot of people would be afraid of the
pushback or they want to be perfect or
they want to get all the information
right I want to encourage you to just
post videos this wasn't a strategy it
was me and pbd talking him just doing
some basic math and the math not being
like perfectly set up as lawyers would
do contracts of a you know negotiation
for what a company is worth in the
crater economy it was just like some
homey math you know just sitting down
but people will get upset
about mistakes oh you didn't say secret
you know Socrates right you said
Socrates so for what it's worth I mean
we learned this making mistakes
in your video can trigger engagement and
so
I've got 10 total tips for you we're on
number six
but if you're liking these kind of this
kind of tactical stuff this is the fun
stuff we've been learning and this is
why I'm so excited for the three-day
challenge that's coming up so again if
you haven't registered yet
today's podcast is brought to you by
learnvideo2023.com
and it's been we only do probably max
four of these a year and the next one's
coming up
for three days five sessions with some
special guests we are going to be
talking all about YouTube and how to get
your first or next 1000 subscribers on
YouTube but also a lot of the tactics
that are working right now for growth so
what's working to grow on YouTube in
2023 and what's been changing on the
platform
um I highly recommend registering and
you can check out the show notes or just
go to you know learn
video2023.com to register for the two 1K
challenge that is happening soon we're
talking about
Why YouTube shorts are like drugs
we had a wild night but dang the next
day sucked and why I love and hate
YouTube
shorts and number seven is
YouTube shorts viewers
are typically a younger audience
now I understand that this data is a
little bit subjective number one I think
I think we actually probably would all
know that and agree on that anyways but
I can let you inside of think media's
behind the scenes and our long-form
videos
um from an audience age
of
18 to 25 that's 30 percent of our
viewers are 18 to 25 on think media
if I click just shorts which it's cool
YouTube studio now allows you to segment
all videos versus shorts versus videos
versus lives
all of them combined so you've seen 11
actually a 12 percent
for being exact
um more of a younger audience is
watching shorts than our main videos so
that's just some data internally to kind
of prove that fact
and here's why that's important
is
even when it comes to cpms people go man
how does cpms and RPMs which is the
technical terms for how YouTube
determines how much to pay you
you know how do I earn more money on
YouTube what are some of the factors
that influence that well some of the
things that influence that is quote
unquote the quality of the audience the
way the world Works in economics work
has a lot to do with like buying power
you know you can't sell a BMW or a
Mercedes to somebody who can't afford it
actually you probably can they just get
a loan and
okay
um but you know
you can't sell something you can't
somebody that can't afford a 10 million
dollar home is not the client type
clientele for a 10 million dollar home
so those are some extreme examples of
saying this
typically older audiences command
Higher YouTube Revenue typically more
affluent audiences let's just call it
professionals professionals business
owners entrepreneurs
people decision makers and companies
that buy software you know the tech
industry
this is why YouTube channel is based on
Personal Finance technology medicine and
channels that reach Elder Millennials
Gen X baby boomers
typically can earn more different
nations and countries have different
buying power and spending power so
that's why advertising why would
advertisers again advertise a 10 million
dollar house to people who can't
actually purchase the house they
wouldn't or they would be foolish in
doing so
so knowing that that's how this works
that goes back to why I love and hate
YouTube shorts is quality seems kind of
like a
could be a harsh world because all
people are valuable and you know but
quality in terms of again is it just a
shallow viewer is it
for think media podcasts speaking
directly to you you know we're trying to
help you build a real business we're
helping we're trying to help you think
like a Content preneur like Jay-Z says
I'm not a businessman I am a business
man and so
you getting millions of views from
people who would never do business with
you based on the money plan you create
for your YouTube channel what good is it
and if reaching a younger audience
is like makes you feel good because of
vanity metrics but doesn't actually help
you
reach your business goals again then
what's the point
good questions to ask
saying that
45 to 64 age 45 to 64 on think media I
combined them
is still seven percent of the 17 million
views we got in the last couple of weeks
so
to also say Well only young people watch
shorts would be untrue
now it's a much smaller percentage and
it was actually only one percent of 65
and up
and one percent of like 55 to 65 and
then five percent of 45 to 55. but if we
combine that as seven
appreciate you you never know it's gonna
do this much math on the podcast 119
45 year olds to 65 year olds
watched
think media shorts in the last 28.
days
so
one of the things that I'm learning is
that the shorts numbers
are like empty calories they're really
big they even look impressive
but a lot of times they're kind of
exaggerated they can make you think a
little illogically
however I'm I'm not going to the extreme
to say they're completely empty calories
because again
and it's not like it's just you know a
13 year old gamer kid who's you know
it's ultimately
it's gonna be thoughtful it's a smaller
percentage that might be your ideal
subscriber your ideal customer your
ideal client your ideal but
000 people
and inside of your YouTube Studio you
can actually look inside and see how
many returning viewers and how many new
viewers one of the things that's been
happening at think media is we just
reached a whole lot of new people and
bottom line
you're listening to this I bet you want
to reach new people
so if you said Sean sum it up are you
saying do shorts or not I would say you
should be doing YouTube shorts
I just think you should be doing them
with a clear understanding
of the pros the cons the bigger picture
and make sure to listen until the end
because
I've got some really important final
thoughts that'll tie this whole thing
together and if you are here live as I'm
doing a podcast recording on the YouTube
channel
smash the like button if you're getting
value today
let me recap you number one YouTube
shorts is the key
the YouTube shorts feed is the key
traffic source for going viral number
two post shorts and weight takes
patience took 150 days 150 days until I
had a short really break out and go
parabolic that's happened for multiple
number three shorts don't pay very well
Number Four Shorts can grow your
subscribers quickly number five
subscribers don't matter as much as you
think they do number six making mistakes
in your video can trigger engagement and
actually a mistake could become a good
thing
number seven YouTube shorts viewers
attract a younger audience
predominantly but not only
number eight not all views are created
equal
so we've kind of made this point but
again
one interesting thing that's happening
at think media grateful for our team
growing and if you ever want to be a
part of what we're doing here we are
hiring work with think.com is the
website
and always see what positions are open
and whatnot
um and we have uh we have a a newer
editor
and it's amazing guy's name is Nathan
and uh we recently did a Content retreat
in Las Vegas where we flew in we're a
remote team predominantly
but we value in-person connections so we
flew in the content team which these
days you know you maybe you've seen
Nolan or you've seen Omar maybe you've
seen Kyle's videos on his desk setup
he's our content team manager and it's
wild because again I'm just a small town
kid College Dropout started shooting
videos in my bedroom I'm
it's just weird how life is and what's
happening and that we're growing and
it's exciting
um and really humbling and really weird
but
it's talking to Nathan and he's he's
like pumped you know like dude the
channel is
like think about how radical this is we
typically get four million views
a month
by the way really high quality extremely
lucrative
think media in the last 28 days as I
look over here made thirty three
thousand seven hundred and sixty dollars
just ad Revenue that's like a pretty
stable you know Baseline and then
obviously Affiliates and we'll talk
about all the different monetization
stuff on the YouTube challenge
but we're literally at 21.7 million
views now this is just total
in one month
I feel like
Jay-Z I don't know why that came to mind
Katy Perry I feel like T Swift you know
smacking it like what's happening we're
just packing out arenas
we were talking about it and
I'm like yeah
what's what's the big deal he's like
dude what are you talking about talking
you know one of our editors
and I was like I mean it was kind of
like empty calories like
it's awesome uh hear me I'm grateful and
it's cool but like let's see where this
goes but like
I don't know not all views are created
equal that's number eight
so I'm like you know what's
and then we're you know calculating the
not a lot of AD Revenue but a lot of
subscribers but what are the quality of
the subscribers
the the debate and I'm curious your take
you know
how do you feel about it you know what
would you how would you feel what do you
think as far as what's happening I think
media here's what it says in my
Analytics
16.7 million more than usual what my
warning would be
is that for many
it this could lead you to maybe make
some poor decisions some of those could
decisions could be
abandoning long form because it appears
that short form is what's getting the
results
I don't think that's true
I think it's cool
but I'm still at that Baseline of that
four million like it's it's this little
sliver compared to this Giant mountain
of views
one of the some of the mistakes it could
make
is
you start getting crazy you think you're
you're blowing up this is your moment
you've made it I try to always avoid
that mindset
for my entire career I've had a seven
million viewed video long years ago and
I remember it happened I was like yeah
it's cool I mean I want to be super
grateful but like
who cares problem is
too many people it's like the rise and
the fall right now dude I'm going by
over with shorts I made it you know what
I'm gonna celebrate you maybe go start
spending money start going in debt
because you're like this this ship has
left the station and I'm gonna ride into
the sunset I've made it
too many people I think are getting too
intoxicated
with shorts views
and it can lead you to being irrational
making the wrong decisions losing being
grounded and this is not me putting them
down this is just Why one of my
brainstorm titles that did not make the
cut is that YouTube shorts are like
drugs we had a wild night
dang the next day sucked
okay number eight is not all views are
created equal number nine this is a big
one
ask whose brand is this video building
so
that number one video
number one video that blew up I start
the video on camera
but I am just the interviewer
you're just inside the mind of the
Strategic mind of Sean Cannell right now
the thoughtful grateful and pumped this
video is going viral but it's also
Patrick but David's platformed is the
expert because he is
I'm interviewing him and again we're
talking about Mr Beast and everybody
knows Master Beast
I've asked you the question whose brand
is that video building
now we also been posting clips from our
growth video live conference whose brand
are those buildings the different whose
brand are those clips building
the personal brand of the person
absolutely happy to do it but just a
good question to ask
you also might say whose brand is it
building think media it's good we have a
media brand and not just a personal
brand that's my vision I want to build
the think media brand
certainly not only but you've not only
just not Sean but like I also I must
decrease think media must increase like
in terms of my vision so here's the
second question for you under number
nine what is the bigger brand You're
Building
I think this goes back to
what can happen with Longs lives and
shorts but certainly YouTube shorts
is
once the algorithm
starts to go crazy you know
once the algorithm starts to suck one of
your videos into the algorithm and and
uh you start getting lots of views
all of a sudden
it can start
leading you instead of you leading it it
starts to influence your decisions
instead of you staying in a place where
you're making decisions based on
principles values long-term vision
Clarity of what your channel is about
Clarity of your business plan as opposed
to just chasing after
more views
trying to maintain
like that would be a really big thing
I'd want to tell the think media team
I am not too passionate about
maintaining this
because if if I was like okay we just
hit 20 million views a month 22 million
we got to keep up the 22 million or else
we're not valuable and we're doing it
wrong if it goes back down to four I'm
fine
that's our Baseline because of
search-based content Evergreen content
so just the question is you know what's
the bigger brand you're building and
whose brand
is this video building that's a good
question to faceless channels and
YouTube automation creators or people
that are doing op other people's content
or people that are doing
um
uh AI content
because I realize there's a lot of
opportunity with
AI content
but whose brand is it building
and
the thing I would be asking
is
if you're going to
actually build longevity on YouTube and
not just experience 15 minutes of fame
it's a good idea for you to be really
thoughtful
about what's the bigger Vision what's
the bigger brand
is it about going viral
or is it about making an impact and
having a clear Mission and a clear
purpose and a clear definition of what
winning looks like
of what success really looks like
so if I'm talking to Nathan it's like
is what we're experiencing on you on on
thick media right now
the definition of success
my answer would be yes and no it's not
my ultimate definition of success
it's the definition
of view success
if the only way you were defining
success was by getting as many views as
possible
then we're being incredibly successful
right now
but how do you define success as a
YouTube preneur a contentpreneur an
entrepreneur is really important
right
and if this put us on a conveyor belt of
just chasing views and chasing virality
that practically again may not be
building real substantive viewership but
also even is not even is finance like
what's actually fascinating is there's a
lot of more factors beyond just probably
YouTube shorts but our estimated revenue
for the channel overall you know how it
tells you it's either more than usual or
less than usual for views subscribers in
your studio
our estimated revenue is about the same
as usual
so
if your definition of success is being
able to support your family you know
pay the bills pay the rent and have your
online business your YouTube channel pay
the bills
then nothing's even changed on our
Channel
which is fine but
all I'm asking you number nine whose
brander is this video building whose
brand is the short building what's the
bigger brand You're Building what is the
vision that you have
for your YouTube channel overall and how
do you define success
and is your definition of success
leading you to healthy habits healthy
behaviors and healthy decisions
or perhaps is your definition of success
leading you a stray
from the vision you started with or your
core principles that matter most to you
personal question
that
I would ask for yourself now by the way
um in just a second I have one massive
principle that changed my life that
helps bring Clarity to this entire thing
right after we hit number 10. but if you
are here live I appreciate you being
here we didn't drop a think media
podcast today so this actually is going
to hit audio tomorrow and I'm just
recording it live here on YouTube so I
appreciate you being here live smash
like if you're getting value
even share this or give me some feedback
about
um some of the questions you may have or
whatnot and I'll look into the live chat
replay or on the comments on hit me with
hashtag replay fam in the comments
um and would love to Circle back and
talk deeper about this on any follow-up
or Clarity questions but let's hit
number 10 before we go into the final
thoughts that I think are the most
important part of this entire video
number 10.
Community is the key to building lasting
success on YouTube
this is not just my opinion here's what
some industry Executives said the real
problem with the shift to short form
video
is that these new subscribers don't
always represent a community
that could be the reason why some short
form creators struggle to build loyal
fan bases
at last year's annual Creator economy
conference VidCon some famous short form
creators with millions of followers
walked around unnoticed or hosted meet
and greets where they said no fans came
to see them
now listen I understand that for most of
us we're probably not never going to do
like a meet and greet at VidCon and be
even at that level what's cool is people
that are in like our video ranking
Academy like you never even have to get
to that level
to go full time you know earn a living
doing this again you don't have to be
famous but let's extract the principle
people who had millions of followers
Tick Tock YouTube shorts
didn't weren't able to translate that
influence at a place where lots of
people were coming to meet their
favorite Creator they they had it was a
ghost town at some of these meetups
the principle is
these new subscribers don't always
represent a community or loyal fan bases
and what I want to encourage you it's
actually something we're going to be
teaching
heavily on day two of our three day
challenge is all about how to build
a highly engaged community
that
can actually support you full time
without a huge audience I would rather
have a small highly engaged audience
than millions of random views I would
rather have a small highly engaged
audience
and
a clear and solid
crater economy business model YouTube
money plan
than just getting millions of views I
would rather have a small highly engaged
audience
that grows slowly and steadily but
doesn't just grow slowly and steadily
this year
but also in 2024
and then in 2026
it's still growing
and maybe I never go viral but in 2028
I'm still here and by that time
it's like
not only is it full time it's got a
couple of part-time people helping you
you know if you're a business owner
you've built up this brand you're
starting to get recognized at conference
more notoriety you're getting to speak
you'd be a subject matter expert because
the channel you've built and it took
some time
and
maybe but there was never any fireworks
there was never any
in any crazy moments there was never
maybe you don't even get a silver play
button
would you be okay
if going all in on YouTube right now or
getting focused Again on YouTube right
now that
by 2028 five years from now
you had
58 000 subscribers
highly engaged
you're making
thirty three hundred dollars a month in
ad Revenue
you're making
another twelve hundred dollars in
affiliate marketing a month affiliate
Revenue
brand sponsorships is about a twenty
five thousand dollar a year Revenue
stream across 12 months
you have created something to sell so
you're earning another
that's probably your most lucrative
thing so you're earning about
58 000 from the thing that you've
created to sell
you're getting
emails and comments from the people
you're making a difference in their
lives and impacting them
and
you have a sustainable pace you're able
to
have a virtual assistant manager email
manager inbox and you're able to
have two part-time video editors that
you're dropboxing footage to to help you
sustain content one's helping you chop
up YouTube shorts and vertical video and
one is helping you with your longer form
video
and you're able to when you want to work
you know 40 hours a week or even 50
because you love what you do but you're
also able to work 10 to 20 and travel
because of the momentum you've built
on the more substantial content long
form
would you be okay with that but no
silver play button and no one really
recognizes you most places like maybe if
you go if you're like in cooking and you
go to like a cooking conference people
come up to you but like other than that
the cool thing is you aren't accosted
at the the Ralphs or the Piggly Wiggly
you're able to just kind of live your
life
work from home have a life on your own
terms and Be Your Own Boss would you be
okay with that
Community is the key to building lasting
success on YouTube
and new subscribers and viral shorts
don't always represent a community and
they don't always build loyal fan bases
what's your vision what are you trying
to build are you okay with sacrificing
ego or vanity metrics or just the desire
for as much Fame as possible and I bet
if you're listening to this that's
probably not your core desire it's not
like you maybe want to be famous however
you've believed the lie that going viral
and having a massive following is the
only way to create full-time success in
the crater economy and it's just not
true
and so this is why I believe that
YouTube shorts
are kind of like post Malone's
relationship with alcohol you know that
one that's a horrible title this doesn't
really make sense
um that this is why YouTube shorts are
awesome but they kind of suck
this is why I love and hate YouTube
shorts but here's one of my favorite
things that I want to land the plane
with
um and that I think ties this whole
thing together
and it's this
um Rich Divini wrote a book called
attributes
and it's all about do you have what it
takes to succeed in any situation and so
according to this retired commander who
ran
training for the Navy Seals
true Optimal Performance goes beyond
just skill and it's all about attributes
this is interesting
because you know how much we emphasize
you need to skill up you need to learn
new skills you need to develop new
skills
but even more important than skills
the author of this book highly
researched the book is very highly
acclaimed says you need to have
attributes they are learnable they are
developable bubble and they're the
things that actually are like the fuel
to the fire of skills they're like the
jet fuel you get the fire started with
skills but attributes are really what
make the difference
and one of the attributes that rich
writes about in the book is resilience
resilience
what does this have to do with YouTube
Everything
and
I would have thought if you said hey
Sean what's the definition of resilience
I I would have thought it means like you
don't quit
I would have thought you know resilience
means like
yeah you know if that person gets a
setback they keep going
which is kind of what it means but let
me give you the actual definition here's
what resilience means resilience is the
capacity to withstand or to recover
quickly from difficulties
it's the ability of a substance or an
object to spring back into shape it's
like elasticity
so if you think about like a rubber band
gets bent out of shape if you stretch it
maybe you have an uncle or a spouse or a
boyfriend who often gets bent out of
shape
they need Grace just continue to love
them right
and maybe you yourself can find that
when the kids are grading on your
emotions or the bad news or a stressful
day you get bent out of shape resilience
is how quickly do you spring back to the
original form
elasticity
so what I love about this is what he
taught about and this is completely
relevant to YouTube and so relevant to
YouTube shorts and just the roller
coaster ride of your YouTube analytics
in general
is
resilience is if you have the best day
of your life the best month on your
YouTube channel the highest high on your
YouTube channel
oh my gosh like we're experiencing right
now at this exact moment on think media
21.7 million views 16.7 million views
more than usual
the highest high resilience doesn't just
apply to the lowest of lows it also
reply replies to the highs
and if you had the highest high
how long does it take you to just spring
back into shape
highest high no big deal on back to
Baseline
back on the grind making new videos
three day challenge later this week
recording a podcast right now Sean how
do you feel about it I'm celebrating it
I'm honoring it I'm grateful I'm humble
did it change anything not at all
resilience back to Baseline just doing
the steady work slow and steady wins
now if you also have the lowest of lows
like oh my gosh my Channel's dying it's
not up green arrows it's down red arrows
what's wrong did the algorithm break am
I being Shadow banned what's going on
I don't know
back to the Grind back to the work back
to Baseline you spring back into shape
if you get pulled up or you get pulled
down resilience as you spring back into
shape
and so when it comes to the painful
truth about YouTube shorts I think that
ultimately we should use them I think we
should do long form I think we should do
lives I think we should do YouTube
shorts but I think we should be we
should have a sound mind sober thinking
and we should be resilient
so literally it's four million views a
month is incredible right like that's
like the Baseline and that's like high
quality search based Evergreen took I
think maybe a long time to build that
and it is literally like
snow piercer keep Snow piercer on the
tracks it keeps Us Alive no matter
what's happening in the world Niche
reference and and we're able to live and
sustain and hire people and do things
because of long-form search based
educational content that has a pretty
high RPM pretty high CPM and that's a
good even Baseline for us that's what
we've built right now there's this crazy
virality but Sean how is it like
changing your decisions or changing what
you're doing it's not Baseline
Sean do you guys ever experience
setbacks at think media yeah like
anybody and even more so just in life in
general you know you're trying to build
a YouTube channel but like you got
conflict with your spouse you guys
fought right before you went live you
know it's true like this is so hard kids
just threw up somewhere came in dumped
your brand new hot coffee all over your
crotch now like your crotch is on
burning from scalding hot coffee just
ruined your pants you got to go live
you're super stressed your camera
battery's dead you thought you're gonna
charge it the night before you're like
this was the shoot day everything is
going wrong got a phone call got some
bad news heard that banks are collapsing
it's kind of hard to keep your mindset
positive in a negative world
resilience
I don't get bad if you get Ben out of
shape like we all do how quickly
do you come back to Baseline
how quickly
can you come back and recover from
difficulties and what's interesting is
resilience is actually the capacity to
withstand to not even be affected I
think one of the biggest ones is the
highs
oh my gosh everyone's saying such nice
things your ego starts getting puffed up
starts going to your head start again a
little bit prideful oh like man I'm
start reading your own mail I'm crushing
it man
like I made it it starts going to your
head pride comes before the fall
so you want to recover quickly
get back to baseline from any from any
of the highs or the difficulties in the
lows
and spring back into shape
my friend I think that that is one of
the most important attributes that you
need in the crater economy is resilience
are we going to lean more into YouTube
shorts and be thoughtful about what
we're learning and double down on them
we already were we by the way it took
150 days for the shorts to break out in
my mind this isn't surprising me I was
like this is the kind of stuff that I
knew would happen because I just commit
to doing the work
and I know that if I do the work today
and I get one percent better with every
upload and these days if I create a team
in a culture and systems and obviously
we're going to be touching on it on the
free challenge we have the seven rvra
system we just keep working the system
and YouTube shorts didn't do much for us
for
about two years mind you we weren't
posting them for about just here and
there for about nine months then
half-heartedly for about six it's hard
to do new stuff
but in the last
two three we've been basically every day
we don't upload a full-length video we
upload a YouTube short
so we just been working the system
Baseline
Sean are you super pumped about shorts
kinda I'm pumped about YouTube all the
things
and it's part of the entire pie
so those are That's The Good the Bad and
the Ugly of YouTube shorts I'm excited
about the future and I think it's also
the wild west Sean what is the Practical
thing I should be doing I think you
should be experimenting I think you
should be testing I think you should be
always doing experiments I think you
should
lean into YouTube shorts I definitely
don't think they're the only thing you
should do I don't think they're what
create Legacy Community and real fan
bases but I think they're a great asset
and a way to get exposed to a new
audience but I'm curious what you think
and again if you're here live with me
let me know
um what your aha moment or takeaway was
from today's episode
um you know drop a like on the episode
and
I actually could probably take you know
three questions because we're gonna edit
this down and I want the audio to be
less than an hour but we're right at an
hour so I appreciate you jamming with me
think media podcast live if you're also
on the Facebook page thanks for jamming
with me
and if you check the replay here
um there are 10 tips lessons and
warnings I have about YouTube shorts
that I would love uh to you to check out
and
check out the challenge
learnvideo2023.com that is starting this
week
we have like a rally tomorrow morning
but the first session is Thursday
morning and we have a session Thursday
morning then Friday morning that
specific Standard Time Los Angeles time
Friday night Saturday morning Saturday
night so it's a three day challenge if
you go to
learnvideo2023.com then you can learn
all of the details about it it's going
to be awesome and I'm super excited not
only do I have three sessions that I've
been dialing in
we're bringing on four special guests
two at a time that are going to be
sharing
their tactical behind the scenes
strategies of what they wish they knew
back when they started their YouTube
channels these are some very successful
creators in diverse niches with diverse
life circumstances
so day one is all about the 10 Things I
wish I knew when I was starting a
YouTube channel with two special guests
that you're going to learn so much from
and then
the final session on Saturday afternoon
is all about how do you get it all done
productivity like with kids with school
with work and there's so many things to
learn there's so many things to do and
these tips blew my mind so these these
are like structured sessions I was just
going through all of the notes Daisy on
our team was grabbing the notes from
um the strategies and the practices and
the habits and the lessons and the
mistakes these creators have made
part-time full-time
eventually hiring a team but before any
of that how'd you do it when money was
low how did you figure it all because I
mean that's I'm sure you could relate
how do you get it all done how do you
handle the time thing how do you
um you know create a great YouTube
channel when you're juggling
responsibilities of family and all these
other things so it's going to be amazing
um Mona yes you do need a Facebook
account it does happen in a private
Facebook group that's just easiest for
us to uh manage as far as exclusive
content and whatnot and so
um it would be worth doing
teacher Kelly tag asks what if I took a
break for several months
I think it's totally fine I think it's
much more about the long term
like what do you do over a five-year
period as opposed to even over a
five-month period
I would much rather you get a baseline
of videos and if you follow the what we
teach which would be relevant I would
assume you're an education Channel
you know this makes me think about when
I had a full-time job and I worked at a
church I
during Seasons like Easter Christmas
certains back to school things were
extra busy during times like summer
things were actually slower people
traveled and so you know the staff would
even break and whatnot so different
seasons of the year I could upload more
on think media in the early days and
other Seasons I wouldn't upload for
weeks or even months however I figured
out how to rank videos so I had videos
working for me when I wasn't working so
Kelly I'd recommend you're making the
right videos and that's what we'll talk
about on the challenge
um in the right way that can actually
still move your channel forward grow
your channel even bring in passive
income even if you take a break for
several months maybe you're even because
you have to teach
um and then eventually the momentum
builds that allowed me you know I built
a baseline of subscribers a little bit
of income coming in and then I was able
to go full time
kind of take that leap but I wouldn't I
didn't go from zero to full time I went
a couple years of working my day job
while chipping away in a particular
while creating videos according to a
particular methodology that we call the
7R system
so that it was a bridge
from my day job to my dream job I
created a bridge
from
the different responsibilities I have
with getting passive views passive
income so yeah it's and then it's it's
okay to take a break anyways because
um it's healthy and I think that's it's
always good as well
um
I'm gonna answer two more questions but
let me also close out the podcast uh
so friends I hope you got value out of
this episode make sure to subscribe if
you're not subscribed and I can't wait
to see you in on the next episode
of the think media podcast
that's it it was not my best outro but
that is something to work with
um okay last couple questions here Sean
can you talk about how you break down
your projects videos or otherwise
um my way of breaking down videos we
call it the perfect video recipe I open
up a Google doc and then I
um
I'll show you how I did this episode
here here for the after party of
of the exclusive
exclusive exclusive exclusive
so
um
here's my hook
of this episode
here's the alternative titles that I I
played with you these all came out of
slack by the way we use slack to
communicate now as a team I've used
things like Trello here's the call to
action talking about our 1K challenge
here's my 10 tips lessons and warnings
about YouTube shorts and then here's
actually the 10 tips that I worked
through here's the rich Divini stuff and
the resilience and that's it so I build
out a Google doc
um and
yesterday
we picked a title and when I say we you
know I brainstormed a bunch of different
titles I'll have people vote on them in
Slack
which if you're a solo Creator which I'm
sure 99 of us are even if you're a
business owner you're trying to figure
this out here's my tip I I would write
at least five to ten titles these days
with like chat GPT
you could easily get 10 titles
um you know of of whatever your video is
about however I don't think they'll all
be good and then in the process of
brainstorming five to ten titles usually
the best one emerges that's also the
most accurate as I was also joking
around like YouTube shorts kind of like
post Malone post Malone's relationship
with alcohol
even that is like a strip like it's like
a creative exercise like anything goes
in the creative process it's probably
dumb but you could be onto something and
and then you're also thinking about
title and thumbnail so because this was
a live stream
um title thumbnail topic was locked
last night
that'd be my recommendation I actually
got ahead of all that stuff
I knew the gist of what I was going to
be talking about but I actually finished
these notes this morning and then that
was my
um outline and so
hope that's helpful that's that's kind
of that's how I did a live stream it's
similar to our process
um when we create videos and the think
media team of course everyone kind of
develops their own style but everyone at
think media uses what's called a Perfect
Video recipe I don't have time to go
into that but there's
um definitely subscribe to the podcast
and check out some of the past episodes
we have taught on What's called the
perfect video recipe
last couple ones I'm missing the
business strategy part of building my
channel what resources do you recommend
that I need to check out for that
missing piece
it would be build a email list
or just how you're going to talk to
people off YouTube could be a text
message list could be a Discord group
but YouTube is going to be a way to
reach your ideal audience but you want
people to be able to vote and volunteer
Rachel for going deeper with you and
there's multiple different ways to do
that check out the pat Flynn episode in
our think media podcast library on
YouTube think media podcast to be clear
is a separate Channel then our think
media channel
and I interviewed Pat Flynn all about
email marketing that's where I would
start Rachel
the real
Lil g197 my lows are uploading twice a
week with average views Longs maybe how
can I get a kick up on the borderline in
the highs
without looking at your channel I would
just keep experimenting and studying
which videos perform well which videos
perform
not as well I would say to your audience
retention curve and I would make changes
and I would try to eliminate videos that
are not performing in your channel and
double down on the ones that are working
um Tory Grace says I highly recommend
the 1K challenge I did at the start of
the year and it was exactly what I
needed I appreciate it Tori and again
learn video 2023 is where you can
register for the free challenge it's
happening Live this week with me this
week live three days five sessions
Thursday Friday and Saturday
limited replays available for free so if
you can't actually attend a live session
you can still be a part of it camera
giveaways
YouTube studio equipment and gear
giveaways these are a lot of fun so we
we love doing these and it's called the
two 1K challenge all the details are at
learnvideo2023.com or check out the show
notes for a link to register and would
love to see you there
last question do titles and thumbnails
matter on shorts
number one thumbnails
are
not changeable on shorts on desktop once
the short is posted
and they said they were going to be
selectable on on iOS but that's not true
for me
I've heard you can select a custom
thumbnail on not custom but one of the
frames of the actual short on Android
I don't have an Android so I'm not I
can't confirm or to deny that but
somebody in the comments might be able
to
and so what I would say I think they
actually do matter but at this point
you're at the mercy of YouTube selection
of your thumbnail
clearly
I would argue they don't matter because
people are succeeding with shorts
without being able to select their
thumbnail
YouTube's algorithm how they scan your
video they're in the goal of trying to
satisfy viewers so they're one the way
they Auto pick what the first frame is
is um
at least what they think will will be
the most interesting frame
so generally though there's not much you
could do for it right now
secondly titles I think titles do matter
in shorts
there is still a desktop experience
there is still
if someone scans the screen they may
look at the bottom and see okay what is
this all about and do I want to keep
watching and there's multiple things
happening they see it but where titles
really matters for search and even
though
it's not the biggest form of traffic not
even close
people are underestimating the
opportunity of search-based content on
shorts
Dan from vidiq I did a stream with them
this morning he was building a video
a gaming PC and he was researching all
the components the GPU the graphics card
you know the motherboard
um what case did he want all the
different accessories what fans or
intercooler did he want and as he was
looking up the parts what he noticed was
that all of the ranked videos were
YouTube shorts as he was searching for
specific product names
titles matter
depending on the content and depending
on what you're trying to accomplish
but everything I just said
is submitted in a dramatic way
to if you want to get real virality with
shorts in a way they don't matter so so
like they matter
for like depending on the channel
depending on the niche depending on what
you're trying to accomplish
even some Niche things we've had some
crazy like we use genius links now to
track affiliate links and we've had
YouTube shorts lead to like a lot of
affiliate sales so there is like some
fascinating ways that are honestly 99 of
creators don't even know
and that you could be earning a lot more
with affiliate marketing than like
YouTube paying you six cents and others
I've heard it's like four or two cents
per a thousand views for their shorts
all that to say
is if it is true that the YouTube shorts
feed is the most viral form of traffic
for shorts which it is and of the 17.4
million views think media got in the
last 28 days 94 came from the shorts
feed I want you to consider the
experience
title nor thumbnail has anything to do
with you really showing up there
I take that back it's not that has
nothing to do
but if you look at my shorts feed
if I swipe
like I'm just there like now I'm I'm
there so there's no thumbnail I can look
down how the Deutsche coin millionaire
lost 3 million I see it's Graham stuff
and I may recognize them and I can I can
look down at whatever's the key to the
Goggins mindset now we got Joe Rogan
whatever and so neither title nor
thumbnail is a part of this experience
as much as the opening of the video the
text on the video maybe a headline
so
it is my opinion that you should learn
the best practices YouTube optimization
you should give content Its Best Shot
especially its best longevity shot
because again too many people cut
corners
on their content today
not realizing that if they optimize
their content properly that content
would keep getting views for them not
just tomorrow but potentially in six
months and even in six years I'm serious
you position Evergreen related topic
YouTube shorts they're going to still
get views in six years some of them
if you could understand that and you're
like well I get it it's a concept that I
can understand as I listen to this sure
but if you could really get that not
just in your mind but like
in your spirit you go oh my gosh
the war the work is worth it
like
I need to master the stuff learn this
stuff I don't want to cut Corners now
because what I'm building
it's not just about how it pays off in
the next week it's how it pays off in
the next year and multiple years
so
long answer
um but I hope that was valuable listen
the challenge is coming up soon so
register it learn video2023.com
um what was one of your ahas from
today's video let me know do you have
any action items anything that you want
to take away from it or that you want to
put into practice
hit the like button if you got value and
um
if you want to learn all about the
perfect video recipe
I've got a four-part series on that you
can click or tap the screen to check
that out my name is Sean Cannell rhymes
with YouTube channel appreciate you
subscribe if you're not subscribed like
the video and I can't wait to see you in
a future episode of the think media
podcast